il n'avait pas dormi depuis combien
d'années m étais tu as fait ce week end
sur l'année délinquants j'ai fait un
camp pour le climat gusty nice était
romain j'ai senti qu'elle avait pharma
d'où ma chérie sur la tête de ma mère
kabli tongs et flore là bas beaucoup
dormi non mais c'est ouf frères attend
on est au même mois mais en fait et
transparentes
je t'adore bloquant une tv dans la paume
non mais sur un billet on voit qu'elle a
pas beaucoup dans l'ue micheline à
nantes un gain staff et l'ama et ben on
a fait les dés on a sur quoi des
épreuves surtout sur le co2 sur la
biodiversité sur les vaches sur le mac
carium la banque non mais moi aussi
j'aimerais savoir ce que ça fait là lite
est d'accord et c'était que ce serait
quoi vous remercie si vous deviez faire
appeler vous deviez faire un truc ou
santana mois dans un nid d'aigle dans un
désagrément
[Applaudissements]
c'est excellent mais sur wiki sua foot
dans un nid d'aigle trois ténors de la
droite et du disney tu crois quoi dans
un nid d'aigle du voyage j'attends un
magasin règle déjà ce que j'accuse à
tort d'aller tu voudrais pourquoi dans
un de mes textes
j'adore les aigles ouais les voir planer
les voir rentrer au nimh et voir les
serres en avant qui tua leur dire tu
parlais gnop je parle corbeau asie
palois nouveau jour que ses voisines
palois et quand je fais ça les corbeaux
alors est-ce qu'on pouvait sortir il ya
des corbeaux dans la région est associé
dans paris je suis battu celle là elle
est choyée garder comme moi je roule mal
à l'aise
écoute je souhaite si son veston beau ça
vole hyper nadal par la savane hyper mal
nourries par bureau pendant une heure